in this series we're discussing how you
can move a little bit more like
spider-man with his kind of agility and
his finesse and his explosive speed and
of course central to this discussion is
the idea of proprioception
that's your ability to sense the
position of your body in space and the
amount of force you're exerting and of
course this is crucial if you want to be
able to dodge pumpkin bombs or run up
the side of walls etc so that's what
we're going to be discussing in this
video so proprioceptors sometimes is
described as your sixth sense of course
this is a misnomer we have far more than
just five senses but the idea of it as a
sixth sense does tie in nicely with the
theme of spider-man who of course has
his own sixth sense in the form of his
spider sense he developed your prior
section then it will seem almost like a
sixth sense as you're able to move
through the air with more grace dodge
incoming attacks etc without necessarily
relying on your eyes and ears and
because so many of us ignore up a fire
ception we don't listen to our bodies in
the same way that we should be that
means that for most people this sense is
almost entirely inert lost you know use
it or lose it it's good news because it
means you only need to do a little bit
of training to get a huge edge over
everybody else prior ception relies on
proprioceptors and these come in three
different broad flavors they are muscle
spindles muscle spindles are stretch
receptors and they tell you about the
stretch in a muscle tendon unit so in
other words how extended your limb is
and whether or not you're in danger of
overextending and causing injury of
course this helps to prevent injury but
it also allows you to assess the
position of your limbs in space by
getting that information from every
single joint in your body know exactly
what angle it is and how stretch the
muscles are and the antagonist muscles
are you can then infer from that where
your body is where each limb is and
create a kind of mental model of
yourself to hold in your mind's eye as
you're moving next you have your Golgi
tendon organs these are your contraction
sensors and they tell you how much
contraction you're exerting in your
muscle and again they can help with an
injury by preventing you from exerting
too much force and then ripping a tendon
from a bone for instance at the same
time this allows gradation of force so
it's thanks to your goal get tendon
organs that you aren't constantly
ripping the tap off the sink which would
be cool but it's not terribly convenient
it's very expensive after a while Gogi
tendon organs are also what allow us to
jump a specific height instead of just
launching up in the air as high as we
can every single time then you have your
Capuchin corpus skills cook but cheats
in the chin Ian Corp uscles called
Pascal's these are the senses in your
skin that tell you about how much force
you're exerting so this will tell you
for instance how much weight you're
putting onto each foot that of course is
highly important if you want to balance
etc when you balance will move through
space your brain is using all that
information coalesce along with
information from your eyes and from your
ear canal and it's using all this
together to help you balance to help you
know where all of your limbs are and not
bump into things etc our body uses
information from our muscle spindles our
perch in Ian called pew skills it
calibrates this with information from my
eyes and from our inner ears and then it
helps us to realign ourselves by
changing the force subtly a lot of this
happens unconsciously without even
needing to think about it of course this
is partly thanks to something called the
myotatic reflex that means that when our
muscle stretches suddenly will contract
the muscle to prevent over extension in
that joint so when you start to fall
forwards that's how your body catches
yourself in tenses embraces to prevent
you from falling without you needing to
think about it is what we call a
monosynaptic reflex that means it only
involves two neurons and one connection
one synapse this means it never actually
goes through the brain it all happens
through the spinal cord that shortening
reflex isn't something that you
consciously control is as fast as
possible because it's a simple
input/output this is an example of a
kind of decentralized intelligence but
most of our reflexes are polysynaptic
that means they have multiple
connections they run through our
conscious brain and they use lots of
inputs from different senses prior
ception
enables us to improve the quality of
those inputs from our body so that we
can make smarter decisions faster and
therefore balanced better
react quicker and move with more agility
so how do you go about training your
prior section while one of the first and
easiest things you can do is simply
listen to your body more and concentrate
on it more consciously so right now
think about where your body is in space
what position are you in where is the
weight distributed on your body are you
holding any tension does anything hurt
feel I suddenly have all these inputs
coming in that you normally ignore and
simply by attending to them you start to
become better at listening to them
throughout the day one
we can do this in a formalized manner is
through body scan meditation this is not
only important to help us athletically
but it can also prevent injury
throughout our lives especially we get
older and we start to lose some of our
other senses if you start listening to
your feet don't wear slippers and feel
the ground beneath your feet as you go
down the stairs you're far less likely
to fall down because you're getting all
that new information from your body that
helps you to write yourself and balance
correctly a lot of the prior steps and
exercises that people recommend involve
things like standing on balance boards
and curling light weights or standing on
one leg and yeah that's alright but it's
only gonna do so much that's more about
rehabilitation rather than developing
awesome body awareness if you want to do
that then I recommend upping your game
with some really difficult balance
exercises things like pistol squats
one-legged calf raises
or better yet hand balancing many of us
ignore the proprioceptive from our upper
body relative to our lower body and if
you want to take this one step further
then try closing your eyes and just
listening to your body balancing upside
down on your hands with your eyes closed
shuts out some of those other senses and
forces you to rely more on your
proprioceptive it's a weird way to train
but it's also kind of cool of course
make sure you don't injure yourself put
a crash mat down be sensible in general
moving with more variety and moving in
different ways will help you develop a
greater body awareness because you'll be
practicing positions that otherwise you
completely ignore of course it also
develops supportive muscles and mobility
that you also might have lost one
particularly popular notion at the
moment is that of animal moves animal
movements involve things like spider-man
crawls or crawling on your back or like
a bear or like a scorpion and basically
moving in ways it inspired by nature a
lot of programs then advise that you
move between these positions in a kind
of continuous flow that allows you to
express yourself as well this kind of
training might look goofy and certainly
some people will raise their eyebrows at
it but that's actually part of the point
in the book animal moves how to move
like an animal to get you leaner fitter
stronger and healthier for life they
actually recommend having fun days so
you spend these doing things like
climbing trees or juggling balls because
playing is learning and in this case
you're learning with your body which is
one of the best ways to develop not only
more agility and dexterity but also
greater plasticity and learning
potential whenever you go into one of
these positions and develop new neural
pathways and actually increase the
amount connect
in your brain is fantastic for brain
plasticity in one cool study it was
found that participants engaging in
cruel training so that means things like
Spider Man crawls and bear crawls along
the ground like we looked at in the last
video so a significant improvement in
their executive function and in their
joint repositioning many studies have
shown that training with novel movements
are able to improve cognitive capacity
it can boost working memory attention
creativity and of course a prior
separative response you can likewise
adapt to move from other disciplines
like Kupwara which is fantastic I did
that for a year
dance of course martial arts other
martial arts one of the biggest
advocates of this kind of training
course is IDO portal who focuses on
training the movement he believes that
the purest way to train is just to focus
on gaining new skills from these kinds
of disciplines rather than just building
muscle while sticking to one discipline
though I'll take away from this is just
to keep introducing lots of different
movements of course you can check out
animal moves specifically or Kupwara but
why not just integrate a bit of yoga try
a bit of calisthenics just don't stick
with a few staple exercises that you
enjoy keep introducing lots of new and
different ideas into your training
stretching of course is also fantastic
for developing reception of course
you're gonna feel the stretch in those
muscle spindles in particularly you
could try proprioceptive neuromuscular
facilitation or PNF stretching this
involves getting into the stretch
position and then slightly contracting
the target muscle before completely
relaxing it weighted stretching and slow
eccentrics are also really useful and I
also advocate using quasi isometric
switch I made a video on this basically
means really slowly performing a
movements like taking a minute to do a
pull-up or a push-up this way you're
changing the amount of force in order to
gradually move up and down it just gives
you much more finesse and finer control
over your muscles training outdoors is
fantastic and I've talked about this in
the past because when you train outdoors
every single movement is slightly
different because the ground is
different levels because the terrain is
different texture because the wind
resistance changes because the tree
branches of different heights and
thicknesses and finally I highly
recommend that you do barefoot exercise
that you either train bare feet
sometimes or that you wear minimal
footwear because this allows you to get
that all-important feedback from your
feet which are perhaps your most
overlooked and possibly also no
crucial proprioceptive inputs today ago
there's a ton of Prior ception training
techniques you can use to move much more
like spider-man in order to move like
spider-man you wanna practice moving
like spider-man that means things like
spider-man crawls but at the same time
you also want to move more like Batroc
the leaper you want to move more like
the scorpion you want to move more like
the lizard practice doing this and
you'll be far more adaptable you'll have
more control and more awareness of your
body and you'll be more athletic in
general so I hope you found this video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like share around there
helped me out immensely comment down
below I have much more like this on the
way soon so that sounds good then stick
around and I'll see you then thanks a
ton for watching and bye for now